bf2
ich grüße sie herzlich sie kennen
vielleicht massimo rocchi den komiker
mit dem italienischen akzent der uns
schweizern dank insider-wissen den
spiegel vorhält
vor etwas mehr als einem jahr wurde ob
die von der universität fribourg gerade
ehrendoktor verliehen
höchste zeit ihn einzuladen und mit ihm
zu reden wir tun das heute um 11 in der
sternstunde philosophie dies nach einem
spannenden auftakt in ramallah
wir leben die christen in palästina
stellt die hamas eine bedrohung für die
frauen da an der uni bei ramallah lehrt
die deutsche politologin helga
baumgarten ein gespräch massimo rocchi
der gebürtige italiener sieht als
ausländer die schweizer besonders klar
was des öftern zu lachern führt der
kabarettist und ehrendoktor im gespräch
ihre möbel sind ikonen der moderne ein
film über eileen gray die sich einen
deut um die konventionen ihrer zeit
scherte
1972 kamen sie zum ersten mal nach bei
rund und wunderte sich weshalb kaum
jemand über den nahen osten schrieb
helga baumgarten begann es zu tun
längst gilt baumgarten als eine der
besten expertinnen des politischen
islams sie kennt die unterschiede
zwischen fatah und hamas und weiß wie es
den christen vor ort geht seit 20 jahren
unterrichtet baumgarten an der
universität von ramallah auf arabisch
eine kollegin julia rieger bei unlängst
in palästina einem land das noch immer
keines sein darf und sie hat sich mit
helga baumgarten zum gespräch getroffen
warschau in ramallah die löwen auf dem
hauptplatz erinnern an wie fünf stämme
cassani discher christen die die stadt
den 16 jahrhundert gründeten
heute sind die meisten bewohner der
stadt muslimischen glaubens die christen
sind eine kleine minderheit geworden
verfügen in politik und wirtschaft
jedoch nach wie vor übergroßen einfluss
so haben ramallah und das benachbarte
bethlehem zum beispiel christliche
bürgermeister seit den 90er jahren dient
ramallah den palästinensern als
regierungssitz und die meisten staaten
haben hier auch ihre vertretungs büros
hauptstadt ist ramallah jedoch nicht
hauptstadt wäre nach palästinensischer
auffassung ost-jerusalem weil diese sie
doch von israel annektiert und später
mit einer sperrmauer vom westjordanland
abgetrennt wurde dient ramallah als
übergangs kapitale ein paar kilometer
weiter nördlich liegt die universität
wien sieht rund 8000 studenten sind hier
eingeschrieben
die mehrheit von ihnen frauen in gesät
werden ingenieure wissenschaften genauso
angeboten wie biochemie französische
sprache oder studien in demokratie und
menschenrechten
wir treffen helga baumgarten in der
bibliothek für women's studies helga
baumgarten wie wird man als deutsche
professorin an der universität von
straight bei ramallah
nun das ist eine etwas längere
geschichte aber hängt schlicht und
einfach zusammen mit meinem
spezialgebiet
ich habe promoviert über die
palästinensische nationalbewegung und
hab dann direkt nach meiner promotion
ein forschungsprojekt bekommen von der
deutschen volkswagen stiftungen über die
universität in berlin die freie
universität berlin und bin mit diesem
forschungsstipendium hierher nach
jerusalem gekommen
hab dann länger forschung betrieben auch
mit dem deutschen orient institut und an
einem punkt ist dann der deutsche
akademische austauschdienst an mich
herangetreten ob ich nicht eine
gastprofessur an der universität
in politikwissenschaft antreten möchte
und das war ein ganz faszinierendes
angebot was ich sehr gerne angenommen
habe und dann bin ich irgendwie hier
geblieben weil die arbeit eigentlich
durchgängig sehr faszinierend war
ganz wunderbare herausforderung für mich
ausgezeichnet arbeitsmöglichkeiten und
ich bin nach wie vor hier im bild und
werde das sicher noch einige jahre tun
und seit wann genau sind sie hier ich
bin nach jerusalem zum 85 gekommen habe
dann an diversen forschungsinstituten
gearbeitet und bin seit januar so 93 in
berät als politologin war das für sie
schwieriger man von als deutsche frau
sich hier niederzulassen sich ans leben
jetzt gewöhnen nein eigentlich unbedingt
ich muss sagen ich habe vorher schon auf
harten der arabischen welt ich war im
rahmen der erforschung von meine
doktorarbeit im libanon habe dort fünf
jahre im wald verbracht hat von daher
guten hintergrund wie es ist in einem
arabischen land zu leben und der
übergang dann bei rot in berlin und dann
wieder hierher nach jerusalem war
eigentlich nicht so schwierig sie leben
jetzt in ostjerusalem wir sind heute
morgen zusammen gegen ihren arbeitsweg
gefahren aus der usa- lemm das nach
internationaler lesart palästina gehört
das aber von israel annektiert wurde
wir sind an der sperranlage vorbei
gefahren durch checkpoints für mich war
das sehr ungewöhnlich sehr aufregend
irgendwie auch beängstigend manchmal wie
sie ist das ganz normale alltag normaler
alltag sicher nicht aber selbst die
außergewöhnlichsten und eigentlich
unmenschlichste umstände können in einer
solchen besatzung situation zum alltag
werden oder werden zum alltag das heißt
offensichtlich ist die menschliche
kapazität fast unbegrenzt sich an dinge
zu gewöhnen die wenn man als
außenstehender kommt unerträglich
erscheinen
von denen man meinen dass ein mensch
kaputt geht wenn er das eine zeit lang
tagtäglich ertragen muss wie gesagt man
lernt ist nolens volens damit zu leben
sie sind ja mit einem palästinenser
verheiratet was bedeutet das für ihre
staatsbürgerschaft für die
staatsbürgerschaft bedeutet das absolut
gar nichts ich habe also meinen meine
deutsche staatsbürgerschaft beibehalten
was meinen status in ost-jerusalem
betrifft so bin ich durch meinen mann
vielleicht privilegiert oder besondere
situation gekommen einen israelischen
personalausweis erhalten
dieser personalausweis signalisiert
schlicht dass ich in ost jerusalem leben
darf und damit habe ich denselben status
wie jeder palästinenser der aus
ost-jerusalem stamm dessen familie seit
hunderten von jahren hier lebt als
menschen mit einer ständigen aufenthalts
genehmigung die einem unter gewissen
bedingungen durchaus auch mal entzogen
werden kann
also das heißt sie und ihre familie sie
können sich in solln israel wie auch in
den besetzten gebieten frei wichtig
genau das also dieser personalausweis
für leute aus ost-jerusalem ermöglicht
einem volle mobilität sowohl in israel
in jerusalem selbst und man kann
problemlos überall hin im westjordanland
reisen wenn denn
das möglich ist als wenn es keine
straßensperren abwanderungen zögerer
eben für die meisten palästinenser ist
das ja nicht möglich also die die sind
sehr eingeschränkte bewegungsfreiheit
wir sind an siedlungen vorbei gefahren
die mauer die man überall sieht trotzdem
die frage ich meine seit es diese
sperranlage gibt hat sich die anzahl der
verletzten und toten die es früher mehr
gegen selbstmordattentate
die hat sich schon verringert oder ja
ich meine das ist ein argument was von
israelischer seite aus angeführt wird
man argumentiert wir riegeln die
palästinensischen gebiete ab aus
selbstverteidigungs grund aus gründen
der selbstverteidigung
ich würde das etwas anders
interpretieren
man kann sagen wie das von israelischer
seite ausgemacht wird die mauer
verhindert selbstmordattentate die mauer
verhindert anschläge
man kann argumentieren ich würde ihr in
diese richtung tendieren das
palästinensische organisation also
speziell hamas islamischer jihad
realisiert haben dass diese
selbstmordattentate kontraproduktiv sind
dass man durch selbstmordattentate
die palästinensische sache eigentlich
diffamiert und genau das gegenteil von
dem erreicht was man erreichen möchte
nämlich ein ende der besatzung besatzung
ist durch diese selbstmordattentate sehr
viel intensiver und brutaler geworden
ich würde argumentieren dass man von
palästinensischer seite aus gesagt hat
wir stoppen diese selbstmordattentate
und würde meine interpretation mit dem
schlichten argument unterstützen was die
mauer nie zu ende gebaut worden ist also
es gibt immer noch teile an der grenze
oder im besetzten westjordanland wo die
mauer der lauf der mauer nicht zu ende
geführt worden ist also wenn man rein
wollte nach israel könnte man das wieso
also ich versteh ich richtig sie sagen
die selbstmordattentate werden auch
sonst zurückgegangen dafür hätte man
keine mauer bauen ist absolut das wäre
absolut meinen augen noch mal zurück zu
jerusalem wenn man mit leuten in
jerusalem spricht dann sagen viele sei
in letzter zeit sehr konservativ
geworden also früher hätte man im
östlichen teil palästinensische frauen
in miniröcken gesehen jetzt sehe man nur
frauen in kopftüchern stimmt diese waren
nicht so ganz schwarz im weiß würde ich
sagen man kann durchaus noch frauen mit
minirock und ohne kopftuch sehen ohne
verschleierung aber wir haben generell
in der arabischen welt und auch in
palästina in palästinensischen gebieten
als teil der arabischen welt eine
entwicklung in richtung islamisierung in
richtung einer konservativen entwicklung
in ihrem slams selbst ist das noch fast
spiegelbildlich in beiden teilen
jerusalems also auch in west jerusalem
ist der anteil der orthodoxen und streng
orthodoxen juden ständig größer geworden
nicht nur in dem traditionell jüdisch
orthodoxen viertel sondern überall in
westjerusalem und die reaktion in
westjerusalem ist dass viele säkulare
juden regelrecht flüchten
nach tel aviv in ost-jerusalem kann man
nirgendwo anders hin flüchten
von daher müssen die wenigen säkularen
palästinenser oder die palästinenser vor
die religion nicht unbedingt etwas ist
was man nach außen hin
im erscheinungsbild in den kleidung
weiter demonstrieren muss das ist die
realität in dem man mit der man sich
auseinandersetzt aber einfach zu sagen
nur verschleierte frauen oder nur mit
kopftuch das entspricht nicht der
realität
eine sendung des schweizer fernsehens
die rundschau hat vor einiger zeit
palästinensische frauen im gazastreifen
genau unter die lupe genommen und
schauen wir doch mal rein in diesen
beitrag
er ist vom september 2011 wir sind im
gazastreifen am östlichen mittelmeer
zwischen israel und ägypten über 15
millionen menschen schätzt die uno leben
auf den 360 quadratkilometern
die gesellschaft wird von männern
dominiert sport und spiel ist für frauen
tabu über 90 prozent sind verschleiert
das sagen hat hier die regierende
radikale hamas der stellvertretende
aussenminister weist den vorwurf der
intoleranz zurück wir sind nicht zu
strikte wie die taliban
aber auch nicht so offen wie der westen
wir sind konservativ und haben unsere
eigenen werte aber wir geben den leuten
ein maß an freiheit innerhalb dieses
systems noch vor sechs jahren also vor
der zeit der hamas regierung hat der
start zusammen mit ihrer gemischten
tanzgruppe in england einen
tanzwettbewerb gewonnen nach ihrer
rückkehr in den gaza-streifen änderte
sich alles die gesellschaft in gaza ist
extrem konservativ nach der wahl von
damals wurde es noch schlimmer ich wurde
von männern verbal attackiert diese
konservative gesellschaft akzeptiert
mich als frau nicht in einer tanzgruppe
zusammen mit meiner letzten frühling
dann der erste erfolg tat kam zusammen
mit einer männergruppe in gaza auftreten
am tag der frau aus rücksicht auf
konservative palästinenser halten sich
vorerst nur die frauen untereinander die
hände der abstand zu den männern bleibt
gewahrt
die kultur änderung kommt just zum
zeitpunkt als sich die rivalisierenden
fatah und hamas in kairo zu gesprächen
treffen und sich versöhnen
anschließend verkündet mahmud abbas er
wolle bei der uno die mitgliedschaft
beantragen
die versöhnung von hamas und fatah gibt
uns frauen mehr chancen am sozialen
leben teilzunehmen
ich hoffe dass jetzt ein umdenken in der
gesellschaft stattfindet dass man offen
und auch gemischte tanzgruppe in zukunft
wieder auftreten dürfen die situation
der frauen im gazastreifen gezeigt ich
gehe mal davon aus dass sie nicht
wesentlich verschiedenes von der
situation der frauen im westjordanland
nun es ist so wie wir im interview
gehört haben
von ahmad josef
dass die gesellschaft im gazastreifen
eine sehr sehr konservative gesellschaft
ist also im westjordanland vielleicht am
ehesten vergleichbar zu hebron im süden
des westjordanlandes jerusalem ramallah
bethlehem sind sehr viel offener
gesellschaftlichen auch traditionell das
heißt die situation der frau ist von
daher im gazastreifen nicht so würde ich
argumentieren als konsequenz der
regierungsübernahme durch hamas so
geworden sondern sie ist schlicht
traditionell anders als in großen teilen
des westjordanlandes was sich verändert
hat seit dem wahlsieg der hamas rothaus
96 ist dass nun auch durch die regierung
immer wieder versucht wird ständige
bestimmte verhaltensformen auch einen
kleinen minderheit vorzuschreiben bzw
immer wieder zu versuchen restriktiver
zu sein in dem was frauen erlaubt ist
aber wir haben das beispiel gehört
männlein und weiblein zusammen in einer
tanzgruppe die möglichkeit als eine frau
ohne kopftuch in gas auf der straße
unterwegs ist ich selber gehe nach gaza
bewege mich ohne kopftuch das ist
problemlos möglich als ich zum beispiel
während der ersten intifada unten war
hat man mir sehr deutlich signalisiert
sie bitte ein kopftuch auf als oder war
hamas nicht an der regierung oder war
noch nicht die große dominante kraft in
den universitäten zum beispiel an der
islamischen universität haben wir einen
campus für frauen einen fünf männer aber
auch an der al-azhar-universität die er
von der fatah also der sich säkular
nennen den verdacht dominiert wird auch
dorthin lehrveranstaltungen zu sehen
für männer und frauen als es hängt der
gesellschaft sehr viel mehr zusammen als
mit einer politischen gruppe es ist ein
auf und ab es ist so dass hamas oft
unter druck der extremisten bestimmende
dinge versucht durchzusetzen wenn die
gesellschaft das nicht akzeptiert macht
die hamas einen rückzieher
sie haben vorhin gesagt ganz allgemein
im arabischen raum nehme die
islamisierung zu der konzern optimismus
auch bei den orthodoxen juden aber
offenbar kritischer wert islamischer
seite wird sie radikaler woran liegt das
das ist schwierig genau zu bestimmen
etwas was sich anbietet
wenn man den vergleich macht zb mit
polen in der zeit des kalten krieges
immer wenn leute in eine krise sind
wendet man sich verstärkt der religion
zu weil man durch die religion durch
verstärktes religiöses verhalten durch
einhalten religiöser vorschriften sich
erhofft dass die krise die lebenskrise
politische krise irgendwie welt werden
kann
ich denke das ist zumindestens einen
moment dann ist natürlich in der
arabischen welt zu nennende einfluss der
iranischen revolution von 79 80 der
natürlich auf die israelischen zeit
nicht in dem sinne wirksam ist aber eben
auch auf der israelischen seite mit
ständige erhöhung der anzahl der
religiösen orthodox extrem orthodoxen
national religiösen juden in dem sinne
eben auch spiegelbild liegen man kann
manchmal argumentiert sie fragen wer
schaukelt jetzt wien hoch also sind es
extrem religiös nationalistische siedler
und israelis die diese prozesse beiden
palästinensern einleiten oder umgekehrt
beide dinge hängen irgendwie schon
miteinander zusammen wir sitzen hier in
der women's studies bibliothek was
studiert man nicht
was hier studiert wird ist generell was
ist die situation der frau in der
arabischen gesellschaft in der
palästinensischen gesellschaft wie in
die weit in ihre rechte eingeschränkt
was den sozioökonomischen status den
rechtlichen status betrifft inwieweit
spielt religion eine rolle spielt
religion keine rolle was ist der
einfluss der israelischen besatzung auf
den status der frau die haben sich
frauenbewegung wie hat sie eine
frauenbewegung in der palästinensischen
gesellschaft entwickelt wie und wo
artikulieren sie frauen politisch das in
so etwa die themen mit denen sich wie
gesagt nicht nur frauen sondern auch
eine ganze reihe von jungen studenten
auseinander setzen sie selbst in der
politikwissenschaftlerin sie sind
experten für den nahen osten
sie forschen vor allem im gebiet des
politischen islam in palästina reden wir
mal darüber und zwar möchte ich beginnen
mit der hamas die hamas wird immer als
radikalislamische zeichnet was meint das
genau
und da müsste man natürlich die leute
fragen ließen begriff überhaupt geprägt
und erfunden haben
ich denke was man im deutschen raum
damit rüber bringen möchte ob zutreffend
oder nicht ist eine andere frage
dass hier eine politische kraft die
religion in einer radikalen oder
vielleicht besser extremistischen art
und weise instrumentalisiert für
politische ziele ich vermute dass das in
etwa die intension wäre es diesen
begriff ständig zu wenden
definiert man denn die hamas richtigen
als palästinenser organisation die den
staat israel beseitigen will mit
terroristischen mitteln und die ein
islamisches der kroatischen staates in
palästina errichten will dass es so die
gängige definition nun ich denke das
geht sehr klar an der heute bestehenden
realität vorbei das bezieht sich meist
auf ein dokument der hamas aus dem jahr
1988 die berühmt berüchtigte karte aber
in dieser charta wurde eben formuliert
dass israel das die juden palästina
unrechtmäßig besetzt haben und dass
palästina befreit werden muss damit dort
wieder ein palästinensischer staat
errichtet werden soll
eine von einer theokratie ist auch in
dieser charta nicht die rede
wir sind heute im jahr 2013 2006 hatte
die hamas an wahlen im westjordanland
ost-jerusalem gazastreifen teilgenommen
und wenn man sich das politische
programm der hamas aus dem jahr 2005
2006 anschaut dann steht er ganz klar
trennen dass die hamas bereit ist
politisch in dem gebiet des besetzten
palästina also westjordanland ost
jerusalem und gaza streifen steht zudem
sind hier drin eine regierung zu bilden
beziehungsweise an der politik
teilzunehmen auf israelischer seite
wurde das in der presse klar
interpretiert die hamas hat im
mit israel anerkannt ich denke wir
müssten wenn wir die hamas heute
anschauen wollen
von diesen neuen status quo ausgehen
man hat dann zwar vom quartett von der
hamas verlangt sehr apodiktisch direkt
nach den wahlen gebt eure karte auf
anerkennt volk israel verzichtet auf
gewalt etc
das kam aber so als druck rüber dass die
hamas versucht hat dem diplomatisch
auszuweichen man hat gesagt wir halten
den waffenstillstand aufrecht also keine
gewalt und wenn man mit einem anderen
land einen waffenstillstand hat dann
gibt's eine implizite anerkennung
wir haben inzwischen immer wieder klare
statements nicht zuletzt vom chef des
politbüros der hamas khaled maschal er
sagt wir sind bereit einen lang
andauernden waffenstillstand eine ruhe
periode mit israel einzugehen und daraus
kann sich durchaus auch einen frieden
entwickeln status quo ist schlicht der
dass die hamas bereit ist mit der
existenz israel allerdings in den
grenzen von 67 zu leben das kann man
durchaus anhand von texten und
interviews demonstrieren was es
gleichzeitig immer wieder gibt sind
statement das ist die östliche
ambivalenz die man auch auf israelischer
seite hat dass es immer wieder
statements gibt hamas wird nie israel
anerkennen genau wie israel sagt wir
haben keine atombomben wir wissen alle
dass ich fehler kann sagen
wahrscheinlichkeit gibt es ja auch
innerhalb der hamas verschiedene
strömungen und es gibt eben gemäßigte
rät die das existenzrecht israels
anerkennen und andere dies eben nicht
tun also wie einheitlich ist denn das
nun ich denke die hamas ist eine sehr
klar durch strukturierte partei in der
es durchaus verschiedene strömungen gibt
aber wenn die parteispitze
eine entscheidung getroffen hat dann ist
die partei so diszipliniert dass man
sich daran hält
also es gibt nicht die möglichkeit dass
die einen dass die anderen was anderes
machen solange wir allerdings in der
situation sind dass israel nicht bereit
ist mit der hamas zu reden werden wir
diese ambivalenz bei der hamas haben in
dem moment würde ich argumentieren würde
ich interpretiere
in dem moment wo es zu offenen
gesprächen auch zu einer anerkennung der
hamas regierung kommen wird wird ein
klarer beschluss seitens der hamas
gefällt dass israel anerkannt wird
solange das nicht der fall ist haben wir
diese verschiedenen artikulierten
meinungen
ich möchte auf einige punkte die sie
jetzt genannt haben noch einmal zu
sprechen kommen
vielleicht aber zuerst ein blick zurück
und zwar ganz an den anfang weil also
dass es überhaupt solche organisationen
wie die hamas gibt hat er mit dem haus
konflikt zu tun und wir wollen ganz kurz
eine rückblende machen wie alles begann
eben dieser ganze nahost konflikt an der
palästina konflikt das ist ein älterer
beitrag ebenfalls aus der rundschau und
zwar aus dem jahr 1977 alles begann als
im jahre 1882 die ersten jüdischen
siedler vor antisemitischen
ausschreitungen im damaligen
zaristischen russland nach palästina
auswanderte
sie machten hier keine wüste neuen urban
sondern erwarben grundflächen deren
bodenbeschaffenheit und
wasserverhältnisse eine gewisse
ergiebigkeit der aquakultur
gewährleisteten immer neue einwanderer
folgten schon die erste
landwirtschaftliche siedlung bett tätig
war hatte eine eigene sogenannte hasche
mehr truppe der offiziell die aufgabe
zukam
die siedlung vor übergriffen zu schützen
mit der einwanderungswelle von 1904
erhoben die zionisten handwerkliche und
landwirtschaftliche arbeit zu ihrem
ideal
sie nannten dass die eroberung der
arbeit der landbesitz der jüdischen
siedler betrug 1885 0 5 prozent der
fläche bis zum ersten weltkrieg hatte
sich ihr anteil dann auf 16 prozent
vergrößert der zionist israel sang will
sagte gibt das land ohne volk einem volk
ohne land
die begeisterung der siedler über den
erworbenen boden war groß doch wem
gehörte dieser boden israel sein will
kamen später zweifel
er sagte es besteht jedoch eine
schwierigkeit von der der zionismus
nichts wissen will
weil er sie nicht wahrhaben will
palästina hat schon seine bewohner
die bevölkerungsdichte des
regierungsbezirks von jerusalem ist
zweimal so groß wie die der vereinigten
staaten 52 bewohner pro quadrat meilen
doch das fruchtbare land gehörte
palästinensischen großgrundbesitzern
sogenannten fn dies die zum teil im
fernen beirut lebten die jaffa orangen
waren schon zu jener türken zeit ein
export artikel ein einziger solcher
effendi machte durch den verkauf von
200.000 hektaren die pächter von 20
arabischen dörfern arbeitslos arbeitslos
denn der fünfte zionistische kongress
von 1901 hat er beschlossen die
arabischen arbeitskräfte aus jüdischen
besitzungen auszuschließen
auch die jüdische agentur sowie fonds
und institutionen verboten die
beschäftigung von arabern
es war ihnen auch nicht möglich ihr land
wieder zurückzukaufen
die zionisten strebten die vollständige
enteignung der nicht jüdischen bewohner
palästina es an
ja also hier ist von einer religiös
begründeten landnahme die rede
und das wird bis heute dieses argument
bis heute so verwendet wir haben
natürlich in der geschichte beides eine
nationalistisch begründete landnahme
nicht zurecht nicht zuletzt auch im
hintergrund des europäischen
antisemitismus und als ein moment darin
auch eine religiös begründete landnahme
die spielt nach 67 eine sehr viel
wichtigere rolle als so würde ich
zumindestens argumentieren in der
geschichte des zionismus ende des
neunzehnten und dann im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert die siedler vor allem die
extremistische siedler im westjordanland
und im gaza-streifen beziehen sich immer
wieder zurück auf das argument dass
estland was den juden von gott gegeben
ist
die palästinenser sind fälschlicherweise
hier die gehören gar nie hierher und das
beste wäre wenn sie das erkennen würden
und einfach das land verlassen würden
wir als jüdische siedler haben diesen
auftrag von gott dieses land zu erlösen
von der präsenz dieser fälschlicherweise
vorhandenen palästinenser und das gibt
natürlich bei der ganzen
auseinandersetzung eine brutalität und
führt zu extremistischen formen der
konflikt austragung die es vorher nicht
in der dimension gibt und da komme eben
auf das argument zurück was die frau
einmal angeführt hatte
dass da eine wechselwirkung ist also die
hamas ist 87 88 überhaupt erst aktiv
geworden während die eher säkulare
befreiungsorganisation unter der plo
ende der 50er anfang der 60er jahre
aktiv wurde also plo gründung 1964 die
vater
seit 1959 diese religiös
nationalistische organisation hamas erst
87 88 zu beginn der ersten intifada und
sehr klar hier die reaktion auf diese
extremistisch religiös motivierten
siedler den mann entgegen gehalten hat
dieses land ist hey ist ein land was
gott in muslimen anvertraut hat und was
die muslime nicht abgeben dürfen
das machte auch den dialog so schwierig
wenn man gott auf seiner seite hat was
wenn man danach abhängen wenn man zwei
fragen jeweils gott auf ihrer seite
haben wird es ganz schlimm aber auf
seiten von israel gibt es eben auch die
die argumentation die die juden sind
überall vertrieben worden
die antisemitischen strömungen haben
dazu geführt dass wir uns nach israel
gegeben haben weil hier der einzige ort
wo sich erleben können nun viele juden
die nicht in israel sind sagen der ort
wo das leben für juden heute am
gefährlichsten ist israel dass das ist
selbstverständlich ein argument und wenn
ich das aus dem deutschen hintergrund
her sehe dann kann man sich einigen
aspekten dieses argument es sicher nicht
verschließen was man gleichzeitig
allerdings auch klar formulieren sollte
ist der staat israel in den grenzen von
67 hat immer wieder die möglichkeit
gehabt mit der palästinensischen seite
mit der arabischen zeitung fragen zu
schließen und hat eigentlich konsequent
über dienste geschichte immer wieder
friedens möglichkeiten friedensangebote
abgelehnt also kissen ist zitiert schon
aus den 70er jahren dass es hatte was um
gottes willen wollen die israelis mit
wem als dem könig hussein kann man
werden
ein friedensvertrag schließen man hat
dass dieses angebot nie akzeptieren
heute sind neben einem punkt angekommen
wo selbst ein präsident wie mahmud abbas
der zu allen kompromissen bereit ist
also kompromisse die selbst von
palästinensern in der gesellschaft hier
kaum mehr zu akzeptieren sind selbst
mahmud abbas ist für die jetzigen
israelischen regierung als
verhandlungspartner nicht mehr
akzeptieren
wir haben vorhin davon gesprochen dass
es die hamas eben doch jetzt auch eine
gewisse vertreter das existenzrecht
israels anerkennen dass sie auch vom
terror abschwören
jetzt ist es aber ich glaube statt einer
unmissverständlichen anerkennung israels
und wirklich auch an eines eine absage
an jede gewalt operiert die hamas mit
dem religiösen begriff des der hut hat
marco stuff anschein stand heißt das
eigentlich ist es dann so dass das sie
von dieser form islamischen denken her
nicht frieden schließen können mit einer
nicht islamischen gesellschaft oder
warum dieser religiöse begriff nun da
sehr viele arabische staaten nicht
zuletzt sich auch daniel frieden
geschlossen haben mit israel ägypten
frieden geschlossen hat mit israel der
auch unter dem neuen muslimbrüder
präsidenten hat muss sie aufrecht
erhalten wird ist das argument dass der
islam das verbietet fehlgeleitet das
gibt es nicht dieses argument der ansatz
von hama ist nur aus dem
israelisch-palästinensischen konflikt
heraus zu verstehen wie aus dem westen
sagen immer warum machen die
palästinenser nicht diesen längst
überfälligen schritt die hamas wird
argumentieren und zuvor hat die plo das
gemacht bis 1988 bzw 93 israel anerkennt
uns nicht und allein israel uns nicht
anerkannt kennt und israel
die besatzungsmacht ist und die stärker
macht ist warum sollen wir als
unterdrückter teil israel zuerst
kennen israel soll den ersten schritt
machen oder wir machen es gleichzeitig
und man muss zurückgehen zu den oslo
vertreten
die ja sehr asymmetrische verträge sind
die plo yasser arafat hat israel
anerkannt israel hat lediglich anerkannt
dass die plo der vertreter des
palästinensischen volkes ist in den
osloer verträgen steht zb nirgends dass
das endprodukt oder dass das ziel der
osloer verträge die errichtung eines
palästinensischen staates sein soll und
was die 2006 demokratisch gewählte hamas
regierung betrifft weigert sich israel
konstant mit dieser regierung kontakte
aufzunehmen
das ist der hintergrund für diese dieses
zögern dieses abwehren dieses spielen
würde ich sagen
mit diesen begriffen huttner auf die man
sich dann zurückzieht ich würde wie
gesagt argumentieren da werden sich
einige hamas leute mit mir dann streiten
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
das in dem moment wo israel die
besatzung bereit ist zu beenden
eine gegenseitige anerkennung da ist
auch die hamas israel anerkennen wird
wie gesagt die muslimbrüder aus der die
hammer kommt wie jetzt in ägypten an der
regierung sind am unmissverständlich
gesagt die camp david verträge und der
frieden mit israel werden
aufrechterhalten
sie haben die fahrt auch schon
angesprochen das ist eine viel ältere
organisation seit 1959 genau die vertrag
gilt als die verhandlungsbereit
die säkulare organisation stimmt das nun
ja und nein
theoretisch fahren die vater historisch
waren die fachleute und die plo leute
und yasser arafat die terroristen und
das war uns auch noch 1988 als der
palästinensische nationalrat unter der
führung von arafat eine zwei staaten
lösung akzeptiert und israel anerkannt
hat das hat israel schlicht zu vom tisch
gewischt
erst 93 also zu den osloer verträgen kam
hat man arafat und die plo und die fatah
anders eingeschätzt gesagt dass ihn die
leute die mit uns verhandeln
die verhandlungsbereit sind aber
inzwischen nachdem der 2000 wieder zum
terroristen abgestempelt yasser arafat
gestorben ist und durch mahmud abbas
ersetzt wurde ist man auf israelischer
seite inzwischen so weit dass auch
mahmud abbas nicht mehr als
verhandlungspartner akzeptiert wird und
ich denke hier muss man einfach auch
nicht werfen auf das was die israelische
politik nicht zuletzt unter netanyahu
verfolgt wo man einfach versucht in der
realen täglichen politik so viel wie
möglich von den 67 besetzten gebieten
voll und ganz unter israelischer
kontrolle
zu bekommen und die palästinenser auf
immer kleineren gebieten zusammen
herrchen richtig zusammen zu parken und
so quasi implizit zu sagen geht es euch
nicht viel besser wenn irgendwo anders
hin geht also die friedenschancen die
wir alle 1993 sehr hoch eingeschätzt
haben es gab kritiker wie adwords der
von anfang an sagte daraus kann sich
nicht entwickeln
dies sind heute beim nullpunkt angelangt
also der konflikt heute wahrscheinlich
schlimmer und unlösbar erscheinen als je
zuvor und das ganze hängt sicher nicht
jetzt ursächlich mit hamas zusammen wie
das oft dargestellt werden wir wechseln
hier nochmals das thema ich möchte noch
auf die christen in palästina zu
sprechen kommt viele leute wissen gar
nicht dass es christen gibt dass diese
christen zu den ältesten christen
überhaupt der welt gehören auch betten
zum beispiel der geburtsstadt jesu liegt
auf palästinensischem gebiet und wir
haben nochmals einen kurzen einspielfilm
vorbereitet der zeigt dass eben zum
beispiel auch der patriarch von
jerusalem wender denn an weihnachten in
die geburtskirche gehen denn nach
bethlehem die sperranlage passieren muss
nur im gegensatz zu uns kriegt er eine
eskorte am mittag macht sich der
lateinische patriarch fouad twal in
jerusalem auf den weg nach bethlehem
er ist höchste repräsentant des vatikans
im heiligen land
die traditionelle prozession heute ein
autokonvoi mit über 40 fahrzeugen
passiert den israelischen checkpoint wir
sind glücklicher weil wir nicht nur den
geburtsort jesu feiern sollen auf die
geburt des palästinensischen staates
dieser starke männer und führer gottes
wille und einigkeit
ich hoffe das neue jahr wird viel gutes
bringen und ich hoffe auf mehr regen
dann werden wir viele glückliche momente
erleben mit dudelsäcken und trommeln
begrüßen palästinensische pfadfinder auf
dem krippenplatz den patriarchen
christen aus aller welt lauschen den
weihnachtlichen klängen vorgetragen
durch verschiedene musikgruppen und
chöre in der historischen stadt in der
katharinenkirche gleich neben der
geburtsgrotte wird später die
traditionelle mitternachtsmesse gefeiert
neben vielen fehlern wird auch
palästinenserpräsident mahmud abbas und
der jordanische außenminister an der
feier teilnehmen
ja frau baumgarten wie leben die
christen in palästina ich letztes team
nun ich würde einmal sagen wir sind hier
in einer universität ursprünglich eine
christliche gründung ist also wird ist
ein historischer ein christliches dorf
das in 50 jahren statt status erhalten
hat und eine christliche familie die
nasa familie hat die vorläufe der
universität bietet als mädchenschule die
da eine gemischte schule wurde in den
20er jahren gegründet 1975 76 wurde dann
daraus die universität börse zu dem wort
des patriarchen würden leute hier aus
münster dies sagen palästina braucht
nicht nur männer und führe es braucht
auch frauen und führerinnen und hier
wir haben zum beispiel eine ehemalige
kollegen ausbildet an einer schraube die
jetzt mitglied ist im plo
exekutivkomitee und eine sehr
partikuliere palästinensische christin
ist christen in palästina stellen
derzeit eine winzige minderheit da
zwischen 16 und 18 prozent
wir haben allerdings zentren also wir
seit ramallah ost jerusalem bethlehem
einige dörfer pizarro christen sehr viel
mehr christen wohnen und andere orte wo
es keine christen geht inzwischen
christen sind eine sehr privilegierte
minderheit
das heißt in der führung der
palästinensischen autorität also der
regierung in ramallah sind sie
überproportional stark repräsentiert in
minister ändern
in der bürokratie der verstorbene
möglicherweise ermordete gründer des
palästinensischen nationalismus yasser
arafat hat als muslim eine christin
geheiratet
und so wie ich das einschätzen hat er
das nicht nur aus liebe zu dieser frau
gemacht sondern da war auch politisches
kalkül und eine gewisse symbolik drin
wie als palästinenser sind muslime und
christen und leben hier zusammen wir
können nicht anders als hier
zusammenleben wir haben einen
evangelischen pfarrer in bethlehem der
einer der sich am dezidierte ssten
artikulierenden palästinensische
nationalisten darstellt und freiheit für
palästina errichtung eines
palästinensischen staates fordern oder
auch der vorgänger des jetzigen
patriarchen michelle sabah palästinenser
war aus galiläa stammt war vor allem in
seiner weihnachtspredigt immer sehr sehr
artikuliert und hat immer wieder israel
aufgefordert den palästinensern christen
und muslimen freiheit zu geben die
besatzung zu beenden
aber heißt dass christen sind hier in
palästina weder diskriminiert noch
verfolgt wie das zum teil in anderen
arabischen ländern der fall ist
ich würde durchaus so argumentieren sie
treffen immer mal wieder individuelle
christen die sagen es ist für uns hier
und da etwas schwierig wenn man danach
stellt sich das eigentlich meistens raus
dass da eigentlich andere in der gründe
für gewisse konflikte vorhanden sind es
ist so dass ich in gesprächen mit
christlichen führen in palästina gehört
habe aus der zeit als die hamas start
wurde als shaq ahmadiyya sie noch am
leben war
dass christen nie so vor empfehlen
übergriffen von muslimen geschützt waren
als zeithammer eine stärkere stellung
hat es gab übergriffe im gazastreifen
die vom extremistischen muslimen der ked
salafisten richtung gemacht wurden
internetcafé angezündet eine kirche
das wird auch von der hamas immer ganz
ganz strikt geahndet
verrückte gibt es in jeder gesellschaft
aber generell denke ich kann man sagen
und ich zitiere jetzt hier ein junges
mädchen die kürzlich 18 jahre alt
angesprochen wurde
wie fühlst du dich denn als mitglied
einer unterdrückten minderheit sie sagte
ich bin nummer eins keine minderheit ich
bin palästinenserin
das sind alle palästinenser und wenn ich
jetzt meine status als christen nehme
dann singe privilegiert und bessere
präsentiert auf allen möglichen ebenen
als die muslimische mehrheit
man ist ja palästina von der uno im
november des letzten jahres als
beobachterstaat anerkannt worden
ändert sich damit konkret etwas für
palästina oder ist das mehr ein
symbolischer eine symbolische
anerkennung nun ist es weitgehend eine
symbolische geschichte was konkret als
möglichkeit für die palästinenser jetzt
mit diesem neuen status gegeben ist dass
palästina vor den internationalen
gerichtshof gehen könnte und klage
erheben könnte gegen den staat israel
wegen übergriffen auf den
verschiedensten ebenen mahmud abbas ich
habe vorher erwähnt wie gesprächsbereit
und moderat er ist hat als eine seiner
ersten reden gesagt palästina wird
diesen schritt nicht tun unter meiner
präsidentschaft ansonsten ist es so dass
die israelische reaktion ihr die war
dass die palästinenser bestraft wurden
für diesen schritt den man in der uno
getan hat für diesen antrag der
erfolgreich beschrieben wurde
konkret vor ort hat sich für die
bevölkerung eigentlich nichts geändert
es gab ja leute die sagten dass sowas
wie die geburtsurkunde eines staates
palästina
nun ich würde sicher nicht so weit gehen
es ist ein weiterer entscheidung der
internationalen gemeinschaft die israel
suggeriert die internationale
gemeinschaft steht hinter einem
palästinensischen staat unterstützt die
zwei staaten lösung das problem ist dass
israel und die usa also die 2 die das
möglich machen könnten das nach wie vor
einfach ablehnen und von daher denke ich
sie mir sicher weit entfernt von einer
geburtsurkunde für einen
palästinensischen staat ich mein die
hammer 1988 gefeiert als die plo ihre
akzeptanz verdienen zwei-staaten-lösung
abgegeben haben die hat man wieder
gefeiert 93 als die osloer verträge
unterzeichnet wurden
inzwischen sollte man vorsichtig sein
vielleicht verbinden einige jetzt
hoffnungen mit dem bevorstehenden besuch
von barack obama in israel das
interpretieren einige dass er sich
vielleicht in seiner zweiten
präsidentschafts periode doch wieder
alle erwartungen stärker engagieren
möchte
im israelisch palästinensischen konflikt
ich wäre eher skeptisch die hasen
verdacht die waren ja seit 2007 verkauft
2011 haben sie sich einigermaßen wieder
geeinigt also wie weit ist diese
einigung ist spricht jetzt präsident
abbas wie dafür für alle palästinenser
nun ich mein das hat er eigentlich die
ganze zeit gemacht als präsident ist ja
durchaus immer von der hamas anerkannt
worden das problem war als seine
präsidentschafts periode abgelaufen ist
hat die amas aus richtung argumentiert
er hat kein mandat mehr
inzwischen ist aber auch das mandat für
die campus regierung abgelaufen
denn da hat keine mehr im mandat zurück
zu kommen auf diese aussöhnung und
machte tatsächlich in anführungszeichen
wir haben auf der einen seite eine
situation wo beide konfliktpartner fatah
und hamas heute sich näher gekommen sind
als je zuvor
man hat sie eigentlich drauf geeinigt
jetzt eine regierung der nationalen
einheit zu bilden man verhandelt darüber
denn wir haben nach wie vor sowohl
israel als auch die usa die das ablehnen
die gegen eine aussöhnung sind und wir
wissen nicht ob mahmud abbas
ob die vater sich diesem druck der aus
israel aus den usa kommenden aufgebaut
wird widersetzen können
die usa und israel und auch die eu sagen
nach wie vor mit der hamas sprechen wir
nicht dass seine terror organisation an
es gibt keine kein dialog eine
verhandlung ich als deutsche politologe
bin heute in einer privilegierten
situation würde ich sagen dass ich mit
einer schweizer schweizer journalistin
rede im schweizer fernsehen und als
deutsche würde ich sagen dass die
schweizer 2006 die einzig richtige
politische entscheidung getroffen haben
nach demokratischen wahlen in palästina
hat man gesagt dass es eine demokratisch
legitimierte partei eine demokratisch
legitimierte regierung mit dieser
regierung halten wir die beziehungen
aufrecht ihnen denke inzwischen sind
alle europäischen regierungen neidisch
auf diese kontakte die die schweiz nach
wie vor mit der hamas pflegt und ich
denke alle denken dass das eine
schlimme fehlentscheidung war dann hat
es sich erwartet man können die hamas
marginalisieren kaputt machen droht
schweigen
genau das gegenteil ist passiert die
hamas ist heute besser verankert in der
palästinensischen gesellschaft und
stärker als je zuvor und sie ist noch
dazu stärker geworden durch die
veränderungen im sogenannten arabischen
frühling in dem er die muslimbrüder also
die mutterorganisation der hamas in
tunesien in ägypten an der regierung ist
und überall
der sogenannte arabische frühling sehr
stark durch muslimbrüder oder
organisationen die der
muslimbrüderschaft also dem politischen
islam nahe stehen mitgetragen werden
das müssen sie vielleicht ganz kurz
erklären wie die hamas mit den
muslimbrüdern zusammenhängt die hamas
gründer waren die führer der
palästinensischen muslimbrüder und sie
haben als organisation der muslimbrüder
in palästina die hamas als politische
organisation gegründet und im der
berühmt-berüchtigten charta steht auch
klar formuliert drin dass die hamas
die muslimbrüderschaft repräsentiert
also hamas leute sagen einem jeder
muslimbruder in palästina ist
hamas-mitglied aber nicht unbedingt
jedes hamas mitglied ist ein muskel
bruder oder eine muslimin schwester es
ist ja ägypten zusammen mit der dahlien
das sind die einzigen länder die
friedensverträge mit israel haben und
diplomatische beziehung erzählen es
gesagt
die jetzige regierung von ägypten die
muslimbruderschaft in ägypten jetzt sehr
stark ist die nimmt jetzt vermehrt
beziehung auch auf zu der hamas was
bedeutet jetzt das auch für die
beziehung mit israel nun die
muslimbrüder aus ägypten hatten immer
enge beziehungen zur hamas war die
mutterorganisation durch die tatsache
dass jetzt ein angehöriger der
muslimbruderschaft präsident ägyptens
ist ist die politische stellung das
politische gewicht der hamas ungleich
stärker geworden und man hat das nach
dem israelischen angriff auf den
gazastreifen im letzten jahr gesehen
dass dieses politische eingreifen
ägyptens zu einem sehr schnellen
waffenstillstand geführt hat das gewicht
ägyptens ist sehr viel stärker geworden
und die hamas konnte aus diesem krieg
aus diesem israelischen angriff wirklich
als politischer sieger heraustreten und
dass die anerkennung der haben als in
der palästinensischen bevölkerung nicht
zuletzt auch im westjordanland und in
ost jerusalem ist ungleich stärker
geworden also das ist eine
eine sehr viel bessere position jetzt
ein stärkeres gewicht sehr viel mehr
bewegungsfreiheit für die hamas als je
zuvor in der geschichte
jetzt ist er im nahen osten wir haben
drei religionen wir haben über alles
gesprochen sind drei monotheistischen
religionen judentum christentum islam
sie beziehen sich noch auf den gleichen
stamm vater nämlich auf aber wäre das
nicht auch bist du das nicht auch
möglichkeit sein über den
interreligiösen dialog irgendwie auch
politisch etwas zu erreichen
die religion spielt zwar eine wichtige
rolle aber sie ist nicht letztendlich
die ursache für den konflikt die ursache
für den nicht lösbaren konflikt ist die
politische einstellung der israelischen
regierung und einer ganzen serie von
israelischen regierungen die nicht
bereit sind mit den palästinensern
frieden zu schließen das heißt ich würde
deshalb argumentieren die lösung muss
und kann nur eine politische sein
sie kann dann flankiert sein durch
solche gruppen die interreligiösen
dialog pflegen aber in religiöser dialog
ist immer möglich
er löst aber diesen politischen diesen
machtkonflikt nicht und das ist das
dilemma in dem wir heute stecken
es sind nicht die gestörten oder nicht
existenten menschlichen beziehungen es
ist nicht dieser dieses problem dieser
konflikt zwischen drei religionen es ist
ein machtkonflikt ein politischer
konflikt und der muss politisch
angegangen werden das ist denke ich was
problem gebannt werden ich bedanke mich
sehr herzlich für dieses spannende
gespräch mit ihm
ich bedanke mich
was übrigens unser team während der
dreharbeiten im besetzten westjordanland
alles erlebt hat das erfahren sie auf
unserer kultur plattform dort finden sie
auch das gespräch zum noch mal schauen
auch eine dvd können sie davon bestellen
bei schweizer radio und fernsehen
redaktion sternstunden 80 52 zürich ihre
e mail erreicht uns unterstand kobinet
srf punkt ch kommenden freitag ist
karfreitag da gibt es natürlich
sternstunden um 10 uhr übertragen wir
den evangelisch reformierten
gottesdienst aus bombe um 11 uhr zeigen
wir ihnen einen film über jesus von
nazareth eine ganz persönliche
spurensuche vom rock musiker und
filmemacher luke gasser
heute aber geht es weiter mit der
gebürtige italiener sieht als ausländer
die schweizer besonders klar was das efd
an zu lachen führt der kabarettist und
ehrendoktor im gespräch ihre möbel sind
ikonen der moderne ein film über eileen
gray die sich einen deut um die
konventionen ihrer zeit scherte